hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage folks yep it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out they
grew up to be classy
or just a big old piece of trash oh boy
i'm your host dates foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here
aunt toody's basement we got a little
family episode going on right now
it's just me and the big dog sitting
right across from me
you could count as pimple as three but
we'll see
kevin james ryan everybody man he's been
sitting on that for an hour while we've
been in here
it's so funny dude you're like a map i
the second you came in i knew you were
gonna say something the fact that you
didn't i said that's gonna be in the
intro oh yeah
sure as [ __ ] i'm like you can't give
this guy an inch save it for the pot
save it for the pot what happened what
what do you mean i got a pimp and then
it was one of those things it's a camera
day
so it's like do you pop it do you not
pop it what do you popped it you went in
of course yeah did you get anything out
of it yeah but not enough
you know what i mean she's deep down
there she's got roots yeah
whatever it is what it is i'm a 40 year
old man with acne do i look at you or
should i look at him what how do you get
them out all right well i'm not going to
laugh at them because
we've been we've been making that joke
to each other for 10 years i'm not going
to fake laugh on the pod what up
everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true to
[ __ ] roof dog
um and then a couple other things
patreon.com
got some new content coming out today
today this drops that's right
the kippy's crib episode is up there
it's about
13 minutes long it's a detailed oh
[ __ ] it's a good one guys check that out
so if you sign up you can get that and
also shout out to everybody we bro
we crush past a thousand patrons [ __ ]
bananas thank you everybody
it means the [ __ ] world to us another
thing what do you got [ __ ] cards are
on sale
what yep ghetto back back on sale get
them while they're hot
holy [ __ ] very limited number
left i know the number that's left and
it ain't a lot and it's not
they'll go but you ordered the same
amount that you ordered last time they
just moved real quick through that
social media
they'll go today so if you hear this the
link's in the description
and then also raleigh on 420
and nashville on 421 get those tickets
live ayg
me and the big man doing some stand up
doing some live ayg with you guys you'll
be asking us questions we'll be asking
you questions it's gonna be a good
[ __ ] time baby it's gonna be an
interactive experience with the audience
it's gonna be fantastic
we're going to the south baby yep we're
coming a couple of yanks
straighten them out again yeah what's
going on flex on them maybe sign up i
don't know maybe they'll turn us
see what happens i'm excited it's going
to be a hot one baby how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire you know him you're
friends with this kid i spent a whole i
spent a whole day with him on saturday
never heard of him got the vibe that he
was getting a little sick of me
he makes us all look good here he's the
magic man you know him as t-bone
mcmuffin
but his mama named them toby mcmullen
sure
what up hey buddy damn yeah me and foley
are road dogs dude
we're [ __ ] bro we broke down in the
jeep we did
better you than me it was it was the guy
the guy is not
a great driver five and a half hours of
spring scene and butt rock
i got to listen to his favorite band
yeah
cannibal death corps or something brutal
one of the most talented bands on the
planet earth and foley's like what is
this like some 41. i was like
rocks you [ __ ] nerd [ __ ] drop-off
kid or whatever the [ __ ] it was called
13 minutes on that on that video huh
yeah it's
and it's [ __ ] fire dude the hot one
baby kid's bucking for sundance over
here
we shot about an hour and a half i think
he's sniffing around for a raise
[Laughter]
absolutely fantastic gang this is a
family episode it's just
us and [ __ ] you guys and we like it
that way
we like circling the wagons every once
in a while we're gonna we're gonna get
through some patriotic questions
yeah talk about some things i just had
something what do you got you ever gross
out a nurse
no i don't think so i just i'm so i'd
made a nurse gag
about two hours ago on the subway
come on folks now i had to go for a kobe
cove test i had to go get a kovi oh and
uh
i had just uh kind of was just
kind of getting my day started you know
like that i had showered you know i'd
showered i'd done everything like that
and um but i hadn't really done any
maintenance in the uh
in the nasal department let's say and uh
she went in for she would got a gummy
bear
she got a little more than she bargained
for huh there's fallout ball for you
a fruit by the foot up there yeah she
she caught a boog
as they would say got a boogie so she
had to throw that one out and do the
test
and it was nasty it was like all right
i'm jump sharing here oh
yeah what the [ __ ]
not everything's shareable okay keep
some [ __ ] close to the vest
it was real embarrassing man she was hot
too
she was packing a cannon on a [ __ ]
ship
the battle of antietam
got pirate nose i take out denzel and
ferris bueller in one shot
shout out to glory fantastic movie check
it out ah
ma'am um yeah also too you were getting
[ __ ] roasted on youtube for your
mustache by the way it's okay
i think any it's great it's great for
the algorithm anytime you change your
look we get a million comments about how
stupid you look
which all helps with the numbers baby i
got a fresh look now i'm gonna shave
your head and bow when you're asleep and
get to get the comments really good you
got roasted so hard it burned it off
torched them yeah i got rid of it i got
rid of it i don't like it
i just couldn't i couldn't go i couldn't
go i couldn't get all the
i couldn't take all they i didn't want
to take off all my facial hair at once
because it's kind of a crutch you know
what i mean it covers up my chin and my
neck and my face i know there's a lot
more visible lines
going on i wish i was like the wolf man
had that just all over
i don't know what that disease is called
but i could use it
i trade one of the ones i got doc i got
the werewolves
i got a bad kid
we can't podcast when it's a full moon
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it's getting dark i gotta get home
you know i gotta get home and staple to
the bed
[Laughter]
yeah all right well this is a papa this
isn't
for patreon but there's a lot of patreon
and got some facebook questions as well
i love that facebook and i got to tell
you we got some [ __ ] heaters by the
way
guys so as you know when you join the
patreon we'll ask your questions we have
a bit of a backlog but we're gonna get
to all of them
the [ __ ] fish are jumping on the boat
what do you want me to do you know what
i mean
it's tough to process it all ah that
being said
we got a couple of good ones a lot of
car related ones i guess because
kippy just got new wheels i don't know
what it is i can't believe i didn't i
didn't
realize that that was uh that was a not
pre-owned car
you got a brand new pretty weird enough
about a pre-owned 2021
kia somebody had it for a week they
definitely jerked off
it's only march do a soup kitchen all
right
um this is from mitchell uh have you
ever had fuzzy dice in your car
no i mean yeah that's what i mean unless
it's a low rider in l.a
you can't be doing that getting out of
your mind i have a couple cousins that
might have had him [ __ ]
but this is when they were hot not yet
not yay
you know we're talking 82-83 you know
it's a tough luck dude yeah i guess if
you're like pulling up to high school or
something you could have them maybe
but you can't be like going to pick your
kids up at school with fuzzy dice
hanging from your corolla this was prime
time
you got to be a kid ish you know what i
mean i had a couple older cousins that
you know maybe they were like 16
17 18 bucks 19 20
hey they had 21 hot they had the white
walls on the [ __ ] tires were they
billy joel who the [ __ ] has white walls
in the 80s
they still had white walls in the 80s i
used to have to clean up that's the sign
of a used car you still got white walls
no it was like a pontiac or something it
was it was hot
i used to have to clean the white walls
on the on the on the tires when they
would babysit us on saturday
shout out to the duck shout out to flow
used to make me clean their white walls
sounded like great guys they were good
was good times we had fun
where did you get fuzzy dice
pre-spencer's gifts
yeah i guess that's when they were like
not ironic cool
yeah have to know someone on the inside
getting put get out of the back of loser
magazine
i went to a casino one time where they
had those at the tables they the fuzzy
dice at the table
what were you on the price is right
[ __ ] gambling on sesame street yeah
what was next blinko ah look at me
shout out to plinko as a kid i was like
nothing more
garbage than plinko every dirt ball in
the world wanted plinko
and i had a strategy i mean you go to
the left you're this [ __ ] keep the
[ __ ] washing machine i want the key
yeah that was like 90 grand if you got
it in the middle right
or something a thousand straight shot
you could get cash
there was one dude that [ __ ] knocked
out of the park you got like a couple of
jihads after yeah they do it i think the
grand prize was either a thousand or ten
that ten thousand seems crazy had to be
a thousand in the middle but you got
like five or six shots
yeah depending on how many questions you
could do a couple of things to get a
couple more
you know what else oh this i [ __ ]
that just brought back remember the wall
that you punch and there was cash in
there
your dad used to do it all the time
there's no money behind the drywall
i thought i had a hundred back here you
don't remember that one is paper of
course
i think you pulled there was that was
another cash prize yeah shout out to the
barker he was [ __ ] letting everybody
wet their beaks in the 90s it's not bad
let me tell you something
uh this is real trashy but i've been
[ __ ] with
uh a little tv network they got called
uh buzzer
which is all the old game shows but it's
like 70s 80s early 90s you got like
password
match game password plus super password
all mark goodson productions it's fun
dude it was it's so nostalgic to sit
and watch that stuff yeah i tell you
those guys really crossed the line a lot
man
yeah they got they got handsy they got
word z it was a lot of like hey suga
tits how are you single that kind of
stuff
you know dude bob barker used to just
smooch him yeah
that's why he had the long mic you just
lift up your skirt with it [ __ ]
scumbag and then sniff it
yeah man other than that it's all right
but you there's a couple of situations
you're like oh there's no way this
all those like uh let's make a date not
let's make a date uh
what's the dating one the dating game
history date or the dating game
or [ __ ] dating game three losers and
a [ __ ] as i like to call it
what would you do if i was an ice cream
game yeah all that [ __ ] but they got
real [ __ ] of the newlywed game
sprinkles on you the newlywed game was
another one yeah where they were like
what are you doing your birthday and
girls were like anal you're like what
the
[ __ ] i [ __ ] broke i was talking about
dinner what are you doing
which is weird isn't it strange that
uh so in like the 50s it was you know
tv had to be like super clean and then
somewhere in like the late 60s 70s early
80s
it got real wild it was the wild west
like i mean the [ __ ] they're talking
about in these game shows
you're jerking off yeah
the little guy's popping up to see
what's on tv yeah
and now like there's no way any of that
would fly
now oh it's weird that like cycle you
know what i mean
it's almost like it follows the rise and
fall of uncut cocaine
yeah barker was doing toots for sure
dude
start doing a couple of sniffies in the
radio room you let a couple of things
fly
uh great question fantastic question
let's see this is enough dude this is a
[ __ ]
uh this is uh from tim big crawl mcgraw
monroe uh have you ever set your gps
direction to avoid tolls
[Laughter]
i i can't believe that this question
came up why you dude
you don't do that are you out of your
mind you're an easy pass man i'm not but
somebody i know is
yeah shout out to mom and dad who were
putting a bill on that one fully's got
the easiest pass
that goes right to the home office i
don't even see the bill call it sleazy
pass with your mom
sometimes i switch hers out keep them
guessing
no was i in new york yesterday
dumbbroad's on the way i don't know
where she is you want to see helicopters
[Laughter]
she's taking that heart medication
no we uh i pick up shaggy over here at
[ __ ] grandson that's a great name
[Laughter]
a couple of scooby snacks for you too on
the ride down
um i pick him up i scoop him up and then
and then uh i'm gonna i'm gonna sneak
out of town through the lincoln tunnel
that's all
[ __ ] up i don't know what was going on
okay like a monkey [ __ ] a football in
there it was a [ __ ]
nightmare you've been working on that
one you were waiting to squeeze that
into a conversation
monkey [ __ ] football i got plenty
more where that came from
um no there was an accident or something
in there so
i kept trying to get down to the [ __ ]
holland tunnel to get
to get to your place now as we discussed
i'm a [ __ ] meat and potatoes guy when
it comes to direction
sure i don't [ __ ] with parkways or
express any of that [ __ ] if i don't
have to sure i go to the turnpike
to the turnpike to my moss how to
mcdonald's
to the burger king to the pizza hut to
the dominoes to the applebee's that's
right the moms
the applebee's that's right i like to
turn bikes because i like to know
especially jersey shout out to jersey
they really do it right on that new
jersey turnpike they got a rest stop
like every two three minutes
they got gas they got snacks they got
roy's which is a big
seller with my family you know what i
mean sure
so the gps kept [ __ ] sending me back
to the lincoln tunnel no matter how many
streets i went down i'm like down at
like 20
uh 21st street on 7th avenue it's like
go back to the lincoln tunnel go back to
liquid tunnel what am i [ __ ] [ __ ]
why are you listening to it what do you
mean why do you don't need it to get out
of the city i kind of do
i'm i'm one of those guys i like to i
like to set it and forget it you know
what i mean i don't like to do it put it
on to go home
i do i put it i like to go back to your
apartment no no not get back to my
apartment but to my mom's because i
don't want to have to think about oh
what do i got to get off
that's why i got the [ __ ] gps listen
my mom's not paying hard-earned money
for this vehicle
sure all right for me to be looking at
[ __ ] directions like an [ __ ]
all right i'll let the [ __ ] car take
care yeah sure so gotta get your money's
worth
i gotta get your mom's money's worth to
get to the [ __ ] holland tunnel which
i knew how to get there but i just i
don't know i get
real ocd when it comes to drugs man we
got on our hands folks he's been living
in new york for upwork
you've been you've lived in new york for
like 17 years and you don't know how to
get that
it's all wonkers down there in the
village i don't know what's going on
[ __ ] streets are going everywhere
there is no excuse for not knowing how
to get out of new york city for as long
as you lived in new york i can get us
out plus there's traffic it literally
took us
the exact length of the film escape from
new york
it took us an hour and a half a lot of
mcdonald's you got to stop at
90 [ __ ] minutes of this psycho so i
had to pick the one at the bottom to get
to the
holland tunnel i had to pick the one no
tolls required okay
and then i forget about it he's yapping
in my ear talking about some band or
whatever i don't know
and then next thing i know we're on the
[ __ ] garden state parkway
like a couple of [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
so i'm
freaking out sure i get i get up the
turnpike and i start
losing it he was in control of the
vehicle the entire time and was like i
don't know what's happening yeah man he
can get lost in a tesla that drives
itself
he's dumb dude that's what it is he's
not i thought
i thought that i had drifted off the
turnpike and and
and got on the parkway by accident but i
realized that my gps you don't even know
what
highway he's on did you just see that he
thought it was impossible for him
to switch highways and not know it
that's how bad of a driver you are
this guy's out to lunch and it's
everybody else's fault
he'll stop at a green light and be like
the guy behind him will be what's this
guy's problem
oh we had a little bit of that too
didn't we almost beat up some hillbilly
in you and you're
in your uh your neck of the woods bye
that cheesesteak plate was was so so by
the way i told you i didn't co-sign this
is more of a hard feeling
i know i know he's dumb i don't know
what do you want from me well you were
talking about directions i'm telling you
yeah then you were talking about how it
took you
then you went into hard feelings is
exactly what you did
have you ever go back to [ __ ] tom's
question
have you ever said it to tolls just
recently yes
this time i have just this saturday as a
matter of fact
but by accident yes by accident yeah
yeah cause our friend rest in peace
chris cotton would drop
he would turn an hour long car ride four
days
with a four dollar toll to no lie a
seven
hour car ride i'd like we're spending
ten times more wrong we'd have to stop
for gas every 35
minutes i remember something funny chris
used to always do
is he would never fill the tank yeah on
a trip
yeah he would like we drove that we
drove to bethlehem pennsylvania which is
maybe
90 minutes maybe six weeks
okay six and we stopped for gas and he'd
be like let me just get ten dollars
yeah and then we'd drive up we would
drive we drive
i don't know 25 miles and stop at
another restaurant let me get another
eight dollars on this one
it was i'm like dude i'll give you 20
bucks just fill the [ __ ] tank
taking us forever to get here he had his
system no i i
hate all that [ __ ] [ __ ] give me the
toe give me the toe i'll give him give
me if i am paying for it
which i don't i want to go on record
which i will not pay for that's a family
plan what do you want from me
oh i'm sorry i have a good support
system yeah as i get my career off the
ground
um that says i get your career off the
ground
because i got an easy i got an easy pass
built for you the corporate easy pass
bill
i get a call from the account where the
[ __ ] the fat man going
she's just driving through the bridge
back and forth i think he stopped in the
tunnel for a couple hours
gang let me ask you a quick question if
you're having trouble in the home
if you have a squeaky door a clogged
sink a wobbly table
you get it fixed right you don't just
leave it unfixed do you no way jose no
so why would it be any different in the
bedroom it ain't
if you're having an issue yeah we have
the answer for you
it's getroman.com garbage yep
go now guys with roman you can get free
online evaluation and ongoing treatment
for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home
apartment or condo townhouse i don't
know what you got wherever you are
whatever wherever you are your parents
basement doesn't matter get it fixed
you ain't got to know about it it's all
a us licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan that works for you
if medication is appropriate it'll ship
to you with
free two-day shipping wow the whole
process straightforward very discreet so
even if you are in your parents basement
they only got to know what's going on
mom's little secret mom's the word uh
getting started is super simple go to
getroman.com
garbage and complete an online visit
take care of your ed without ever
leaving your home
complete the online visit today and
connect with a health care professional
and take
care of it what are you waiting for baby
i don't know go to getroman.com
garbage now and you'll get 15 bucks off
your first month that's crazy i ain't
talking because i'm talking
hard cold hard kids 15 bucks who
couldn't use that these days 15 clams
in your pockets it's really time to take
care of your id and remember get started
today and you'll save 15 bucks on your
first order of ed treatment
gang as you know uncle heck and kippy
are trying to quit smoking like a lot of
people out there
gotta get off the bernies i've tried the
patch i've tried the nicotine
gum i've tried the inhaler next thing
you know you're just getting addicted to
the gum and all that stuff and it all
stinks
it all stinks the gum chews your lips up
yeah it's no good
but our friends at fume have found the
solution
fume took a look at the world and
noticed that the solutions to quit
smoking
like patches or nicotine inhalers were
neither desirable
nor easy to use in response
fume has hand-crafted beautiful wooden
pipes
to make the quitting process simple and
easy
and desirable you got to smell this
thing it smells like heaven
yeah they sent us a whole bunch of them
they're awesome it's not a fantastic
it's not a vape or anything corny like
that it doesn't use nicotine but instead
uses these little cores
they're like little pieces of you know
uh like cotton balls or so
they're infused with the world's super
plants that are known to help you
successfully quit
smoking from start to finish plus they
taste pretty
good delicious as well it's easy peasy
you slide it in there
you take a couple of pulls on it
everything starts to work
so head to breathefume.com that's b r e
a t h e f u m.com the link will be in
the description
make it easy for you and use our promo
code garbage
check out the variety of plant infused
cores to start
today their conquer cure which they sent
out so we've all been
pulling on the past couple of days is
the number one q
number one core for quitting smoking
fantastic so guys go to the website
breathefume.com
and use our promo code garbage today now
back
to the show uh another great one for
cars
from tyler ever kept the dealership
license plate frame on or the magnet or
the sticker after purchasing the car
which is funny the frame i i noticed the
frame and i was kind of proud that i had
the frame
yes frame yes trash
yeah i got the heavy they gave me the
medal that day i got to steal
front and back new york that day really
damn how'd you get it that day
i don't know i don't know what they're
doing over there at the key dealership
but they're moving in shape but you got
it from the dealer
yeah what do they have a couple of
prisoners there or something like that
i don't know it is a kia dealership
making them up fresh i don't know
fresh plates i got shanked when i go in
for an oil change that doesn't make
sense
they gave me the metal right there to
steal bang bang he's like i gotta put
these on there i said you do that
son i'll be catching a bernie saying
goodbye to the teego you got uh
you got those new new york tags too the
white ones pretty sweet they're pretty
cool i feel
i gotta say i'm a dork i'm a loser this
is the first time i've ever
owned a new car i feel i concur it feels
nice
to have a brand new car with new york
tags oh man
it's cool it's nice cool i feel cool pa
is okay
pa is okay it's nice jersey's all right
jersey used to have those sweet ones
those baby blue ones back in the day
yeah they were real [ __ ] nice you can
always tell a piece of [ __ ] car that
still has them
they're always they're still in like a
taurus or something that's how we knew
we were almost down the shore
that sounds scummy [ __ ] highway
you're on now
let alone when you were a kid going down
the shore i don't know what's going on
um fantastic question this is from gary
do you talk hold on i'm sorry
about that dealer thing i always keep
the dealer thing on there
and i would usually maybe take the name
from that and give that to the car
because i had
i had a martin and i had a murray one
was murray dodge harry dodge
i used to be married a lot of cars from
mary of course yeah
they think they went under
i still owe a couple payments you're
hemmed up if you're lending my family
money
wait what's the name of that place mary
dodge
what you say that like such a
philadelphia dude yeah i'd say i am what
i am
murray dodge mary dodge mary dutch yeah
he's going to mary's
yeah go down there get me a dodger over
there
shout out to fc kerbec what's fc kirby
that was a car dealership in the great
northeast
oh man i've been there ain't that great
the great door here
the northeast ain't thanks i got a shout
out to my cousin brendan he said that
joke [ __ ] a decade ago
fc kerbach his things were it was called
beauty visit our two locations in the
great northeast
or beautiful roxburgh my cousin because
i've been to roxbury
and ain't that beautiful and the
northeast ain't that great
yeah dude do you have a voice for local
advertisements oh i love when i go back
and you like hear on the radio yes come
on damn i'm like
it's i'm like this is a [ __ ] from a
bad movie
talk about garbage my dad will sit and
watch those infomercials
for the yeah because he doesn't know
what's going on for the locals he's
waiting for this to come home
he's watching this right now i love you
big guy shout out to the big man
but he watches sorry about the easy pass
tough break big man
um he watches the local infomercial for
the local car dealership oh great my dad
used to watch those too that's insane
also too yeah one girl's pretty hat my
dad used to watch too for some reason
on like channel 21 they used to do it
was like an all
uh african-american dance club and they
used to do line dancing you know what i
mean like the
like the electric slide type day like
that kind of like not like cowboy line
dancing but like
and they just would be on for like four
or five hours dude my dad would [ __ ]
get a big plate of chips
a couple [ __ ] sodas and hang out and
just watch that
i guess he liked the music and maybe he
was taking some pointers or something
he was hanging out it was dude it was so
low budget it was like
it was locally it only went to like nine
tvs it was like super local
he's trying to learn how to talk to
blackjack i try to make his move
i've never seen it in any other tv but
it wasn't on my mom's head it was
nowhere to be found only it might
have been a special package we had
ah good stuff uh all right this is uh
this is from renee trueblue screwed in
kid fielder
shout out to historians uh have you ever
scraped the ice
from your car windshield rear windows
using a credit card
credit card no cd case cd cases credit
card
ain't too shabby though probably it gets
you in there yeah cd case was
not the best it was a little wonky they
broke quick the best until
they would break was the actual cd i
used to do that with like a burnt cd
wow yeah if i didn't have a [ __ ]
scraper who had a scraper i mean
i don't know they just invented those
next couple of weeks ago i didn't i
never even knew of those
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen in my entire life i got in my
buddy's car
he turned it on and this [ __ ] like
like backstreet boys or some [ __ ] came
on he goes oh my [ __ ] sister was in
the car he
ejects the cd and threw it out the
window i had a buddy do that and my mind
was bozo and
cds were still like 20 bucks yeah
incredible and it was like
i forget what cd was it was a rap cd
that he bought and was like frustrated
with it
and he was just like it was supposed to
be good it might have been he bought it
chopped and screwed remember chopped and
screwed
they slowed it down so when you drink
promethazine it would be even slower
so the song was like [ __ ] who
whatsoever that was how it played on the
cd it was called chopped and screwed and
then when you got when you said
the name of the song no as a style of
music they slowed down rap
even more it's a houston thing dj screw
yeah that has to be a dj screw song for
it to be officially chopped and screwed
but it has become its own genre of music
well at the time it was uh it was what
the
[ __ ] shout out shout out to screwed up
click um you would drink promethazine it
would slow it down even more so it was
what's promethazine scissor sip and
scissor
cough syrup oh what are you a [ __ ]
nun all of a sudden
robitussin yeah no like permit i did
adult drugs like a [ __ ] grown-up not
drinking cough medicine
meanwhile i was addicted to [ __ ]
starburst over here
fully you would love it it's a
prescription strength uh
cough syrup that's full of [ __ ] i'm
listening that's it's an opioid
and you mix it excellent you mix it mix
it with soda and put a jolly rancher at
the bottom
ah interesting look over he's got two
plastic cups
stay tuned for a hot new bonus episode
chopped and screwed
over there on patreon i'm gonna slow it
down i'm gonna get my scissor upon
um so they would slow it down because
you'd be all [ __ ] up and it would slow
it down even
just like it would trip you out even
more ah man
and whatever we my buddy bought it we
were like so hyped we were like pulling
out of the oxford valley mall parking
lot and it was a chopped and screwed
version
[ __ ] tossed out the window my mind
was blown grow some balls and get a coke
dealer what the [ __ ] you're drinking
scissor how are you doing you used to
dip blunts in it too ugh
you ever get wet i've been playing this
all week foley
you've been playing this all day
uh great question great um this is from
gary uh do you talk gary do you talk
with a cigarette in your mouth
[Laughter]
what am i an old mechanic yeah that's a
tough the smoke's going in your eyes
right right right
right right i tried to pull that off for
so long yeah you it's
it's the cooler version i think i don't
know
it doesn't i can't do it i can't do it i
don't look cool you end up eating them
just get shorter and shorter i'm gonna
burn my lip
nah i never looked cool smoking i always
felt like when people
especially when i when i got larger
bigger
put on weight hey you're not that big
okay um
really chopped and screwed
i whenever i smoked i would see people
looking at me like oh my god he like i
don't think i didn't look good smoking
what would that what would the people
think
they would think that i was i'd look
like a loser like a fat pig smoking
is that what they think is that what you
think that's what my head would tell you
because i don't think
anybody ever stopped and told you that
excuse me sir you look like a fat pig
that's
that's all on you this guy's bonko's
yeah
isn't it willie you were saying isn't it
weird that like
like when if i had a smoke i quit smoke
i'm completely done
no nicotine gum no nothing i'm not dumb
i'm not touching i'm done i'm off i'm
off the skag
all right watched you smoke a cigarette
on saturday
in his defense i think he told me sunday
yes
it's tuesday pretty good
the last one you had was sunday so you
went monday
sunday and monday you said you had one
sunday i didn't say that you said the
last time i talked it was sunday
no i didn't say that when was like can
you prove it all right okay
prank caller anyway point being look
over here i'm smoking
[Laughter]
full don't you worry about my lies
but if i have a body i stopped years ago
if i have a cigarette it smell
ice i smell like [ __ ] yeah but if i feel
like if an attractive
uh person has a cigarette they don't
smell as
cigarettey they almost smell good
they're like that well yeah it's not
mixing with slim jims
there's a lot of cured meat on [ __ ]
on dudes with tight bodies okay
fair enough
good looking dudes are walking around
smelling like swedish meatballs all
right
shout out to ikea shout out don't need
an allen wrench for that
open up some [ __ ] sweeties
love the swedish meatballs yeah they
were a horse for a long time
what they got caught yeah they got
caught you didn't know that
what yeah yeah yeah toby doesn't believe
me immediately goes to the computer
they got they got they got beat up bad
they got hemmed up [ __ ] belgium i
guess
swedish you know whatever uh still
keeping an eye on them yeah they got
they got they got jammed up pretty bad
damn swedes eating horse meat yeah
they're [ __ ] bonko's those guys
geez it was only in europe that don't
count yeah
i care what you do over there that's
like the wild wild west yeah you cross
the 59th street bridge
better be ground beefing those meatballs
buddy tell you that right now
we're using a family recipe yeah
my friend joe riemann schneider eats all
the time
gets it from his butcher
all right this is from dylan dylan shout
out to d bone
uh is it trash or still wear a hoodie or
a t-shirt from a job that you've quit or
been fired from
yeah buddy if you're rocking a [ __ ]
pizza hut shirt on out on a friday night
yeah it's trash i never had that problem
because i never
i destroyed every piece of clothing i
ever had from from a
like restaurant like an act of like
defiance no it's like an act of being
fat because i got [ __ ] all over it when
i was [ __ ] working i was a slob
towards the towards towards my end of my
tenure at the old bear burger
my shirt was disgusting yeah you always
had like waiter you could
even you had clothes that were even when
they were clean they were dirty
like you like the waiter that shows up
in like the pants so you're like
you went too long without washing those
things and now they're just permanently
yeah dingy ain't enough shout in the
world to get that [ __ ] out
bonus points if you ever used the old
uniform to get an employee discount
right in if you've done it because i'm
sure somebody listed his ass
that's so weird no what if i show up the
[ __ ] pep boys wearing a pep boys
outfit
i work here i swear
see you on tuesday get on the intercom
ask for yourself
[Laughter]
would uh henry come to the front desk
having another you see what i tell you
can the cashier give henry ten thousand
dollars can the cashier give henry ten
thousand you heard the man
[Laughter]
get the [ __ ] out of here no ah
you're a penny pincher like that you do
this keyboard is cheap he is a cheap guy
i'm looking at a bunch of cameras that
would say otherwise that's not you just
because you won't
invest in yourself but you're a penny
pincher yeah
yeah no i'm just frugal broke poor still
yeah
that's all changing we're coming up
um what was it going to say hold on i
want to know
which place did you do that no i didn't
say i did it i was saying if someone who
listens
i would have dude i wouldn't put it past
some of our listeners are
savages yeah i wouldn't even know what
you would do what do you put on like a
mcdonald's shirt hey i work here
let me get some fries yeah yo i once
i worked at a i worked at geno's east in
chicago they opened up a brewery
gino's east chicago come by yeah they
are down here roseman
try the upside down pizza you won't know
what to do with yourself
but you'll burn your tongue takes nine
hours no they opened up a brew pub it
was fancier
so i took a date over there and then use
my employee discount because i worked at
the other location
i hope he didn't have sex with this
person of course i did they went on a
date with me
ah jesus did she know that you were
pregnant with your employee discount i
think so
oh did you make her pay half what no no
no no no
no no no at regular price i'm
technically
the employee so it'll be coming out of
mine i don't remember you working
saturday
brunch last week um that's garbage
i worked i worked at acme the
supermarket growing up
and they gave me uh a fat a family how
much is
spaghetti how much of you work here
how much of the loose rolls now do i get
a discount because i used to bag
groceries here
hey my manager sent me over to get some
loose rolls and old pickles
remember the pickles in the in the
barrel ah
the kosher pickles oh my dad was a big
kosher pit guy
if your [ __ ] grocery store's deli
counter didn't have that big ass [ __ ]
barrel in the front with a bunch of
wooden background
pickies in there yeah you're doing it
all wrong you were bobbing for pickles
my mom used to let us she said we should
get her own picture i was saying using
your mouth
butt cheeks first you're poofing the
pickles
[Laughter]
those are the big boys too henry yeah
look over here
hey um but we had
they gave me a card like a key card like
so you'd swipe
like your bonus savings card or whatever
key card but like it goes on like your
key chain
oh you know what i mean like the little
ones and they were hey do you have you
have those you're trash
you have your super shaman eight million
oh yeah yeah eight million
yeah yeah um my mom's a janitor of
savings
uh she you swipe that but it would give
you a
ten percent off of your groceries so i
gave one to my sister
and then she used it until they were
like she used it for like a decade after
because like they didn't like stop it or
whatever she got kids [ __ ] the weekly
the way the
she did the order the formula the
diapers ten percent off all that so
packs tampons but i remember at one
point they were like yeah where did you
get this this thing's from like the
[ __ ] 80s and they were like yeah this
stuff we don't do this promotion anymore
so they [ __ ] snatched
ah what the [ __ ] she's going in the back
and grabbing a pallet of wonder bread
[Laughter]
let's see this is for miles shout out to
miles
you ever put a jacket or a hoodie over
the garbage in your car to hide it
before picking someone up
wait what have you oh just oh just okay
like cover the mess i picture like a
trash bag in the passenger seat and you
put a jacket on
yeah put the seat belt on at first so it
looks like you got some muscle with you
make it look like a person
uh yeah for sure i would do that yeah
yeah whatever
i did that with him on saturday yeah
yeah okay
yeah uh yeah i was i for some reason
i had a beach towel in my car i guess
when we were down the shore or something
and uh we never used them they were just
folded in the back and then somebody was
getting in and i was like
[ __ ] i like nicely placed it over it
was like a flamingo beach towel which
looks worse than the trash but yeah you
gotta you gotta [ __ ] keep up
appearances
yeah i like trashing i like putting my
trash in there though
you know what i mean because you're lazy
no it feels like yours and then you
clean it out and you get it you know you
get a detail get the car
locked up that's the most insane logic
i've ever heard in my life
it's like throw trash in your car to
make it feel like it's yours it's your
space
you're just used to living in your trash
that's what march that's what identifies
your space is sitting in your own
you did not think this one out this is
your laziness because you do it here
you litter all your [ __ ] behind here
your [ __ ] boogies yeah that's gross
it's laziness
there's a trash can nine feet from you
it's full your trash collects you behind
you
it's full of the trash over there yeah
why don't you take it you don't even
know where to put it
i'd ask you you put it in your car
[Laughter]
save it for later hey i call trash
put some sweatpants on them
fantastic um let's see here this one's
nuts this is from put some respec on my
name
master p i know that one no little petey
uh petey bird
birdman birdman right
is that who it is that's who it is this
has been word association with an idiot
[Laughter]
folks
do you ever retake fast food cup fast
food soda cups
when you go back to a place i assume to
not have to buy one
we got this question a couple times
actually like will you go to mcdonald's
with a mcdonald's cup in your car
and then fill that up so you don't have
to buy another drink do they let you do
that you can just hand them the cup and
say hey fill this up no a lot of places
you do it on your own
oh outside no so you're taking your own
cup
under the disguise that you've you
bought it i'm a drive-through man i'm
not
i'm not walking hey can you fill this up
hand it to them
i was just here yeah no i don't [ __ ]
with that
yeah that's nuts i don't even like doing
the water cup
i buy it i buy it it gives you the
anxiety you're gonna get caught i know
i'm not giving some [ __ ] jerk off for
the chipotle the satisfaction
of kicking me out before i've enjoyed my
bowl i'll give you the [ __ ] 250 for
the mr bibs i don't care
yeah make sure the chips are fresh i
feel the same way
uh i think i've done it like once or
twice and it is just anxiety and i feel
like a piece of [ __ ] yeah i mean listen
if you're
a parent and you know you got [ __ ]
four kids and you got to take in the
mickey d's
yeah i'd make those little rugrats
[ __ ] hang onto them but then what's
that teaching them
you know sure next thing you know you're
using your [ __ ] employee id
on a date
like a grease ball yeah ah this is a
[ __ ]
home run uh this is from no famous
franco do you
uh have you ever owned an electric dart
board
[Laughter]
i knew you weren't gonna know what that
is that's too many words for you
the one that doesn't have the the one
that's what's electric mean
boogie woogie my dad's dancing
do the hustle it was all she looked like
daddy loved watching it
we would just sit there and watch it oh
my god
um electric electronic dart board what
are you not getting about
slo wait first of all you're yelling at
me all right not see no i need a
cigarette
and mcdonald's somebody give me a cup
there's some trash around me
i feel more in my space you look over
your bob
got your head in the truck are you
talking about the ones that don't have
points on them but the the dartboard has
holes in them
yes yes uh what's electric about that
what do you mean well that that tail is
the tail he's the score it what it was
i can't say that word say it again it
counts the score
it accumulates the numbers say foley
just outed himself
as just being the biggest piece of
garbage because he has used an electric
dartboard but he's never used one that
has been plugged in or had batteries
yeah no those don't work
[Laughter]
your mom never let you plug it in
because she's a wacko um
yeah they were real trashy yeah you
gotta go classic like we have that one
over there that was like 34 bucks or
something yeah you gotta go that's the
[ __ ] classic one we don't have a
potato we should have a potato though
for lunch a potato you put a potato you
put you put the
darts in the potato keeps them sharp you
never heard that
yeah you get a you get a potato okay
baked your fried
you chop it up drop it and drop it in a
pan of oil 350.
i like to mash myself now you stick it
you stick a potato you stick them
in a potato okay and it keeps the
[ __ ] darts sharp
okay what aren't you getting about this
pimples you said we need
one yeah you want to catch sharp darts
[ __ ] embarrassing
people when they come in [ __ ] like an
[ __ ]
uh great question fantastic
well that was so to me that was the
thing of the 90s where it go
like the late 90s where they were like
let's [ __ ] make
everything electronic right it was the
it was the idea of
think plastic super cheap we can now
have the technology to do this
and make it affordable to people but
it's like so
unactual usable trash you had to like
get it perfectly in that little hole
yeah and the darts were plastic they
always bent they were socks like what
the [ __ ] i remember i went over my buddy
i'm like dude this thing stinks yeah
well she couldn't throw it again smoke
sticks or something
yeah that was awful that i remember when
they when they [ __ ] up the etching
sketch they try to like make that
electron
that's a sketch yes they made that
electronics something an ipad
watch a movie police [ __ ] watching
lord of the rings on an etch-a-sketch
trying to make my smiley face i used to
be mean on an etch-a-sketch
really i was terrible at that [ __ ]
it was terrible really i picked you as
an artist but they also they all
remember when they tried to make
battleship electric that was actually
pretty sweet
yeah yeah i don't think i've ever
completed a game of battleship
i always lost interest or ate the ships
i just wanted to play with the ships i
take the pegs
i cut the pegs off of them and i have
here in the bathtub that's a [ __ ]
teenager
no you know we used to have when i was a
kid and captain crunch you would get a
submarine
and if you put a little baking soda in
there it would it would
it would in the captain crunch no in
this in the submarine
they'd give you a little submarine i
gotcha i follow you all right you buy
captain crunch
come on not you let's go you put a
little baking soda
you put a little baking soda in there
and it would die it would like swim in
the water
pretty sweet yeah sounds it um keep your
mind off when you're getting
finger blasted by some babysitter
he was nice keep your eyes forward um
that was always weird i had a buddy who
was like he lived in new york and i
moved up here and he had a kid he's like
hey you need money you can babysit i'm
like
a guy babysitters aren't a good [ __ ]
lord we did that
once and it [ __ ] really backfired on
the whole family it was a situation
they're smoking inside and stuff it's
not good now
my cousins that's a different situation
of course they would watch us of course
but
it was one of those nights where the
where the multiple families went out
like my mom my dad my uncle my aunt
they all went out yeah and somebody gets
jim to come over
this i remember this just it was a real
tense in the house when he walked in i'm
like i don't know
i feel like a german shepherd i didn't
like this guy i was i was growling at
him
shedding everywhere and then something
weird happened later on in the evening
which he was never
i don't think i ever saw the guy after
that
yes sounds like a nice night out
jesus christ um
this is from patrick uh patrick when was
the last time you illegally dumped
something in a dumpster
illegal was this guy a [ __ ] cop
what am i supposed to do with it leave
it somewhere illegally dump something
and
that's what dumpsters are for unless you
put a chain on it you don't want me to
throw my [ __ ] in there
yeah well like behind like a grocery
store or something yeah something that's
technically what would be an illegal
dump you're not allowed to put stuff in
those
technically everyone you've ever taken
since i had some nachos last night
yeah no well you get no flights
you didn't have notches last night i
don't know what you're not i don't know
what you're not agreeing
i didn't have notches last night i
showed you no
i didn't ask you a question you turned
on and go no
what am i a [ __ ] dirt ball what am i
done with it what do you mean
uh we were a big dump family i mean in
my fraternity house
we had a bunch of nitrous tanks in there
and then the national chapter showed up
on expected one saturday
and we threw them down the hill on 95.
i don't know if that counts i don't
think so yeah no
uh no we used to go throw [ __ ] in
dumpsters okay
i've gotten caught when they were like
get that out of you're not allowed to
have that [ __ ] you who's telling you
that
they're well they're private dumpsters
the dumpsters aren't like for the public
that's the dumbest thing i ever heard if
there's a dumpster if there's a dumpster
behind a kmart
you're allowed to throw your trash in no
you're not well what are you supposed to
do to leave it somewhere
what do you mean that's what's gonna
happen what do you mean leave what trash
somewhere
it's a trash can trash cans are for a
dumpster is different than a trash
can okay
so like a dumpster that you would like i
know what it does i don't know
i don't know where well i don't know
what the best place is i don't think so
you throw in like i'm not saying like
throwing a bag of mcdonald's
in a dumpster that's a yeah that's
illegal you're telling me
technically yeah i'm saying wheels
illegal gross stuff we used to like
take like my dad would always just take
stuff from the house and go find a
dumpster
like he just didn't like trash around
the house so we would find a dumpster
ever he'd
take a dumpster every day i don't
understand like he would find somewhere
like where why would you put it in the
[ __ ] trash can and wait till trash
day cause he was a [ __ ] weird dude
that and like if he ever had like a bet
or something you had to get rid of we
would just go find dumpsters i'll throw
it in oh yeah stuff like that
yeah that's what i'm saying i got caught
oh yeah beds air conditioners all that
[ __ ] this is incredible this is fully
learning about
not only a new crime but a new crime
he's committed repeatedly yeah i don't i
don't understand it
yeah you're not allowed to do that right
it's private yeah they're paying for
that but you get you can get who's
paying for it
whoever the dumpster say you go to like
a townhouse community center or
something
right yeah they're always wide open yeah
but that's how they get there's a lot of
eyes on you because all the people are
like i mean it's like pooping in a hotel
what's you know you're no they have to
pay to get
moved and you're going to pay that
you're going to well i'm saying that
you're if you're a business you're going
to pay to have that dumpster whether i'm
putting my mattress in there
sure but you have when you you fill it
that's what i'm saying so then
if you fill it with a mattress they
can't put their stuff in and have to get
it pulled quicker which then costs them
more money
hey tough break it's all from charity i
love how he went from not knowing what a
dumpster was
to no i don't do that yeah we do that
all the time i don't know what you meant
now who's going to give you [ __ ] about
that a cop's going to come and bust you
for that no you're picking it up
like if a [ __ ] say it's a
construction site the people like you
can't like get the you're not allowed to
do that that's
our private dumpster i wouldn't know if
there was construction guys around
i'm not saying you are but you asked me
a question and then defended yourself
against the quest i'm not saying you
would i'm just saying
that's who says that stuff if you go to
like a [ __ ] apartment complex
the super you know what i mean something
sure yeah
whoever dumpster it is okay let me ask
you say you come down from your building
and you have trash in your car
will you throw it will you put it in
like a at somebody else's trash can out
in front of another building
like a person's yeah uh or buildings
or do you think that's what do you mean
like buildings like what building has a
trash can
every building has trash cans they're
all in the alley or behind the thing
okay check this out it's illegal to dump
trash in someone else's dumpster without
permission getting caught doing so is
punishable by
500 plus fines and possible jail time
can you imagine that what are you in for
i threw out an old mattress
yeah watch out for me uh no i'll save it
for like a wawa a 7-0
like if it's in my car i'll well like we
have
i also invited there's trash cans on the
corner so i would throw it in that or
something yeah that's what i mean
yeah yeah yeah do that yeah okay but i'm
not we're not talking trash i'm not
talking like a bag of like
a [ __ ] soda can and a bag of chips
talking like
large pieces of objects to throw in a
dumpster i got you yeah like a couch
a couch yeah a [ __ ] yeah you
paint was always a big one we always had
to make paint cans disappear
that was i remember that was always a
thing you're just drinking them
you could well you couldn't put them in
the in the trash yeah they'd get you
yeah do you stop doing whatever you're
doing to your finger because it looks
gross
i'm not sure what you were doing but
you're making eye contact with me and i
could see you zoning out
okay i was playing with my cuticle
i mean this guy is something else today
what do i mean
[Applause]
uh oh nice time i know
enjoyment you [ __ ] stonewalled me on
the last two
questions electronic dartboard and
throwing something in the dumpster you
acted like you didn't know what either
one of them were and then
had a very staunch opinion on him at the
end of the conversation
well don't ask me criminal questions on
on a videotape
ah man all right this one's from tony p
uh tony p
have you ever borrowed a friend or
family member's handicap parking permit
so you could park closer
ooh that's trash
yep it is my buddy steve had one in high
school and
i i what did he get he just had one like
he got his
he was he was like a guard dealer like a
used car dealership no he just had the
point i gotta have the plate too
you gotta have no it can just be in the
hook oh really i don't think if you just
have the hook i don't think it's almost
gonna be like let me
let me see your [ __ ] handicap cards
or whatever he's just taking someone's
word for it you know what i mean
but we would like pull up to the mall
and he would i felt so bad he would park
in front of the mall and like
four stoned [ __ ] park in the mall
four stone teenagers would get out
everybody'd be like these guys aren't
handicapped you know what i mean we're
like [ __ ] shoving each other and
playing crab ass
wow yeah i felt real bad yeah we were
never allowed to do that stuff that was
there's some things that the foleys
don't don't cross
yeah you know we i just caught you
[ __ ] digging your nail again
we we you know we may do a lot of things
but something like that you know
we have lines that we draw sure yeah we
don't we don't take handicap parking
okay
that's good yeah um all right this one's
from mike
uh is it garbage or travel everywhere
you go with a backpack
yeah i hate [ __ ] backpacks especially
if you're on the [ __ ] subway and
you're an adult
man take your [ __ ] backpack off you
take it off yeah
they say what are your questions in
there who's what the [ __ ]
like all right you have a backpack sure
but i'll give you that backpack
because that backpack's not packed with
[ __ ] sure
what do you got in there i have my
computer for the show it's all work
stuff i'm not like rolling out on a
[ __ ] tuesday afternoon with the back
with like supplies
i got my [ __ ] computer i got my
charger
you know that's that's mainly it maybe a
t-shirt a book
yeah a dildo yeah backpack guys get the
[ __ ] out of here well new york's a
little different
i guess major cities are different
especially like
new york as a comedian or whatever like
you you and you have a day job you leave
the house you gotta have a change of
clothes like you were
we used to be out for like [ __ ] 15
hours
16 hours a day so it was like i leave
the house at [ __ ] 7am and i can hold
two in the morning or whatever
i need supplies true you know what i
mean i gotta have a change of call i
gotta change out of my jerk all business
clothes
i need i need a pair of jeans i never
understood that what because you look
nice in your business clothes i would
just wear the same thing all night
you do that now foley's doing spots in
an apron
it's got a hair net in the butt the
ticket out writing down people's orders
write my jokes in there one of the big
trays
i got a busboy behind you
we're getting ready to drop the
appetizer
fire the entrees um
they're annoying though the guy in the
backpack it's it's so weird too
especially in new york because you'll
see [ __ ] like
dudes in suits right like i used to work
at like a very prestigious
huge law firm like very very it's top
shelf as high-end as you can get
and i mean the lawyers were worth
millions of dollars
and they would be in there like [ __ ]
whatever they're like nice
suits you know what i mean and then
they'd all be like [ __ ] they'd have
like big
backpacks on wouldn't that mess up the
suit yeah i'm like you look
like a [ __ ] really big third grader
like trying to get to the bus
you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] stepping
out of the bins with a jansport is
tough yeah yeah they look like a
seven-year-old businessman they were
always the same guy the guy in the suit
with the backpack
almost undoubtedly would pull up in the
the foldable bicycle
is the biggest [ __ ] dork machine
yeah is anybody with a foldable bike has
ever gotten laid i don't know what the
[ __ ] to tell you
it's a top those are top things are
brutal those guys are always
dicks yeah they always have like elbow
pads on and stuff
someone get a [ __ ] taxi to hit him
dude
well you know what's funny what's even
worse so it's up in
uh where i live up in the heights of the
george washington bridges right there
so you see all of the people who are
don't want to pay the toll
for the commute every day because that
toll is like 16 clams
it ain't cheap so people don't want to
do that every day according to my mother
they live right across the bridge or i
don't know whatever
they're biking they're bikes scooters
you see you see guys
in suits on like rollerblades and stuff
and you're like what are you
dude how are you [ __ ] scooting up to
any respectable job like that you look
like a bozo
the guys on the scooter zipping around
the city hit the [ __ ] bricks
i don't i disagree with all that and i
know de blasio's real big on this little
inside baseball in new york
de blasio's big on he wants bought more
more bikes and more buses
and less cars get the [ __ ] out of here
this is new york city
those bike lanes are a [ __ ] nightmare
plus they're [ __ ] popping out like
[ __ ] maniacs they don't listen
they don't respect any any lights or
anything they're just zipping around
because they know if you hit them or
they hit you that you gotta [ __ ] pay
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] what was the
original question i don't know backpacks
yeah
yeah lose it um this is a no for me this
is another one this is from jesse
uh did you ever have to fetch a hubcap
as a kid when your mom nicked a curb or
something
i assume you've had to go running out
into the turnpike to get one
it's not going on i tell you
child safety really goes out the window
when you [ __ ] when you lose a rim
i'll tell you that right and oh yeah
i've shagged a few of those
really oh yeah we had a
[Music]
i don't know it had to be a mid 60s um
not a falcon uh a we had a ford matador
like before we got our first like real
family car
that like i can like they had like when
before we were born my parent my dad had
like a camaro and [ __ ] something they
had a nice jeep like a family jeep
when we were like we were like babies
but then when we moved to philly we had
a ford matador and this the hubcaps
would pop off on this thing
like a [ __ ] hot wheels and you'd be
like you'd almost be driving with the
door halfway open
trying to get it as it's rolling off
ready to make a move
like cap shield or something like that
yeah i don't think
we never that never happened to me
whenever my mom never really she was an
alright the only time she ever hit
she hit one of the pretzel vendors one
time remember how they did you just
stand out
did you do just to stand there and hold
and sell pretzels like on the court like
the busy corners
oh yeah philly oh for a dollar oh
favorite
brown paper bags we had three silly soft
pretzels and they would sit there they'd
have a crate that they would buy for
like
you know probably 20 bucks for the day
or whatever like allegheny avenue or
something yeah yeah yeah we always get
we always got them at byberry and
[ __ ] like right at woodhaven and
byberry that's the guy she hit
he was she was buying them and then he
bought i don't know what happened but he
was walking across and
after she bought the [ __ ] i'm in the
back having my pretzels
and the next thing you notice poor
schmuck comes flipping over the front of
the car
over the windshield really yeah he found
he was like oh man he popped right up
like
you're good all right your mom's like a
[ __ ] forgot my mustard
yeah dude it was [ __ ] she he full he
you know she flopped that dude damn
yeah the piece no hubcaps but she was
taking out pretzel vendors
for sure um yeah that's garbage
yeah hubcaps in general are trash what
were they thinking with those they don't
have keeper
but they don't have hubcaps anymore
right less because technology has
changed and you can now
rims are cheaper to make right before it
was
they were the rims were expensive so
they made just the black shitty rim and
then
clip a [ __ ] hubcap on there so it
looks the same
yeah i mean interesting yes yes yes uh
this is from big texas jensen who i
think is our boy's uh
jen uh were you ever i think we've
touched on this before remember the last
kid who was picked up from school or
practice
i've never multiple yeah yeah yeah i've
been left a handful of times yeah it
sucks
yeah it was always my dad my dad always
left me somewhere it was like super late
yeah sure sucks i usually gave a pretty
tight attitude
when that when that happened yeah well
you feel like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
especially if people are like waiting
for you like i got left to
school the one time i don't know if
there's a musical communication of like
my mom picking me up for my dad i think
i've told this i'm hoping he would just
not come home
i was in like the [ __ ] uh it was like
an after school program
uh we've you've made fun of me for this
and he left me there one time was it
football
no it's cheerleading then you're a dork
no it's i was in
elementary school it was because nobody
my mom wasn't home
afterwards key kid yeah the big headed
room
put him with the other other other other
other other other other other other big
put him in this padded room but the guy
with the girl who thinks she's a horse
[Laughter]
shout out to laura really oh yeah did we
talk about this
i don't know you went to school with a
girl who thought she was a horse
oh yeah oh yeah trying to slip her your
carrot
me out at the table scumbag no she would
obviously you know i'm a veterinarian
obviously something bad something
socially emotionally
you know mentally she was all there i
don't know obviously
oh you think there was something wrong
with her yeah thanks
obviously i'm not walking around
thinking i'm seabiscuit yeah
you weigh the same
could use a biscuit huh it's everything
daisy is coming up around the corner
oh no laura has overtaken her on the
inside well sh
yeah um she um man that's
real [ __ ] up yeah and obviously this
is back in the day where like
schools now know how to handle that they
just they were like let her go
you know so and all the kids too
everybody was super nice to her because
it was like
wait a minute hold on she legit thought
she she was a [ __ ] she didn't talk
very little a lot of nays and the
i swear to god yikes yeah she was like a
senator
yeah i'm not sure i got that one yeah i
mean
i laughed at it and i'm like oh they're
not doing it either all opposed
nay oh man man this guy i'm opposed to
that joke
[ __ ] nothing on that come on it's
this whole thing's a setup
t-bone you really gotta connect the dots
sometimes it's like tinker tail or
soldier spy over speaking cogni over
here
yeah bonnie rubble trouble
[Music]
yeah and she thought she was it was a
problem
so what's she doing now last time i saw
her she was working at
bringing it to belmont
she's glue
[Laughter]
everybody had to put her down they're
making meatballs out of her ikea
all-in-one bring it back that sucks
a poor kid um she was yeah she was super
not
yeah she but she would um she would
stand in the back like if we had a
lineup to go to like gym class or
whatever
she would stand there with her one foot
oh you know how the course is staying
with like the one phone
i had a lot of anxiety when i was a kid
i couldn't handle that i [ __ ] need
this like a hole in my head
it was it was very normal back then
she was she went to school though since
kindergarten so like by second grade
you're like yeah that's her
what'd you go to school the x-men
academy what do you mean that was
normal i do i mean like you're just like
okay she thinks she's a horse i mean
you're not gonna
there's not a lot of meat on the bone
you can only make fun of it for so long
yeah that's her thing you know what i
mean
[ __ ] so she was accepted everything else
i mean
it was fine her parents were they would
come their parents were
wacky yeah they were probably goof balls
which [ __ ] the kid up
yeah but um the one time
there was uh there was a sub and
she would set she was allowed to just
kind of do whatever she wanted you know
what i mean
so she set up a bunch of chairs what
class were you in when
what do you mean i mean usually i mean
i'm older than you
oh i know and those situations are
usually how do i put the selfie
they were sorted out they were you know
there were certain classes for certain
people
yeah yeah so my question to you is what
were you pretending to be
that you were in the you were on [ __ ]
noah's ark with the [ __ ]
what class was that football helmet
no just she was in regular classes i
don't think she was i don't think you
were in regular classes
this is coming from a guy who doesn't
know what electronic dartboard is and
then
i was in normal classes
normal raccoon classes
kevin the squirrel teacher was an
alligator
everybody turn your face turn your books
to page 32 everybody
it's just a big alligator all right i
mean guys come on
no normal class i think uh because
mentally she was there emotionally
they were so like whatever man i don't
[ __ ] know
the whole school knew she was a horse
girl and they just let her [ __ ]
sounds like you hooked up whether you're
trying to justify it to your friends
she's mentally she's all there um
she's doing okay now you know i saw her
working at a fast food restaurant oh
really oh yeah i mean she's got it
together okay she's doing all right
um fries were a little soggy but
i want to talk to your manager let me
talk to them
let me talk to your jockey this is
ridiculous yeah she can't work at the
counter cause she gets spooked when
people walk behind her
she's kicking the guy just kicking the
guy on the grill
[Laughter]
she's gotta work back at house
hey i needed to cover tonight laura
threw a shoe
ah that's terrible i'm telling you man
we didn't make fun of her but the one
time
so we had a couple situations like that
too yeah there wasn't really a lot i
thought he was a beaver
[Laughter]
no it's just it wasn't uh and even for
the 80s i i think this is pretty nobody
really messed with anybody that had like
a situation
they they they weren't they weren't
[ __ ] with yeah no
i'm telling you were a jerk that's dude
it was so normal but if you were fat
oh man if you if you were a regular
civilian
[ __ ] and the boys came in you got it
and you got it good
we had a couple of serious bullies in my
[ __ ] schools coming up
yeah kids that were like hit by their
parents that would come in looking to
take it out on somebody
and man did they oh it wasn't
i had a velour i had a i had a maroon
velour
sweatsuit that i wore once
[Music]
it was a long day yeah and that's tough
too when you're just like
you're hemmed up you gotta like maybe
take the top off so it's not as
much put the top in the locker see if
somebody has gym shorts or something
i'll never forget it man it was a maroon
like adidas
[ __ ] sweatsuit that like didn't have
it was like they were like almost like
pants they were sweatpants
but they didn't have like the the cuff
at the bottom they were just
oh man straight legged oh yeah straight
length i don't know what i was thinking
look i look like a little gym teacher i
don't think you were little
dude we got to take the power back from
these bullies we got to get you a
[ __ ] velour maroon jump shoot rocking
on a pod yeah right
looked pretty good um that reminded me
one time i
wore uh so it was high school it was
probably high school early high school
nine tenth grade i think i was getting
driven to school probably you know it
was like
i don't know whatever i was 15 16. and
those mornings it was so early and not
like all the lights weren't i remember
like
a handful of times you would get to
school and be like what the [ __ ] did i
choose that like or
something you know what i mean it just
but i took early i flicked the lights on
to brush my teeth and [ __ ]
i wasn't getting dressed no i just
remember like there was something that
was like wrinkled or a stain
what are you the other woman sneaking
out of the house no
i didn't get it um but just
the one i'm just saying things are
moving quick in the morning you're not
you're
not you don't have all your gears aren't
going to have all your bearings you know
what i mean you're more likely to make a
mistake
pants are on your top shirts on the
bottom so
i uh i had a sweatshirt a hoodie that i
guess was left in the washer too long
and i got to like the first period class
i'm like [ __ ] is that smell it has that
moldy smell and i'm like
[ __ ] is that smell and i was a fat kid
so what i didn't yeah aquaman
hey mold boy
moldy ryan over the adventures of mold
boy
um and dude even worse i think it was a
bad laundry there or something i didn't
typically i always made sure i had a
shirt under
the sweatshirt that i could wear i could
take this but i had something like
really tight that was like
optically worse than the smell was of
the hoodie
so i just had to [ __ ] hem up and have
this thing or dude
talk about self-conscious oh man
i was a tough one tough
i was like we got cologne like i was i
didn't have gym that day but i'm alone
this is high school yeah oh man
yeah that's a tough one i know [ __ ]
moldy ryan over here
yeah that's gonna be the artwork that
everybody does moldy ryan
yeah it was a tough one i remember shout
out to [ __ ] aj who hit me with like
some [ __ ] eternity by calvin klein to
douse on myself
yeah we all took our lumps you know what
i mean yeah okay of course
she just said like you were wrapping up
a musical or something we all took our
lumps that's what we did
um all right let's rip through a couple
of more here hot cues baby i gotta give
it to the [ __ ] garbage
they got some hot [ __ ] fantastic this
is from austin we've touched on this
before
playing the law the lawn sprinkler drink
from the garden hose for sure
big fan big fan big fan of the sprinkler
ice cold
yeah you caught it on the side of the
house where the sun wasn't
and it was cool it's coming out let it
run for a little bit
clean living yeah what was it baby uh
this is from kim have you ever used a
washing machine as a cooler at a party
that is top-notch trash wait like
i knew you weren't gonna understand that
put ice in the washing machine yeah
what do you do with the ice afterwards
melts it's a washing machine they filled
with water
it's pretty ingenious when you think
about it wow
yeah throw a load of whites in
everybody got cool water in there turn
it on a little bit shake it up get it
moving
make jungle juice it's the perfect high
school crime yeah killing a guy with an
ice pick that's no evidence
that's not an ice picker that's true
yeah yeah yeah
that's not true that's just murder
[Laughter]
ah damn that's [ __ ] trash
yeah never done it like we've talked
about like you make that the bar
cover with like the red plastic thin
thing from the dollar store yes
put an ice bucket on there a couple of
two maybe three liters if you got
company coming over
yeah yeah yeah nice bottle of maraschino
cherries fresh
cut up a couple of limes but i never did
that
yeah um yeah that's real trash
i think in college
if i'm not mistaken the bathtub was
turned into
uh a cooler
at one point that makes sense filled
that with ice and put the beers and all
that [ __ ] in there
it makes sense i guess yeah hotel rooms
i'll do like the you know you always got
to do the [ __ ] the sink
fill the sink with ice dump the beers in
there in the hotel room you do that now
like as
just you and your girl go somewhere what
sink are you using
we stay in nice hotels that typically
have two sinks last hotel the
the last hotel we just did that i put it
on instagram two sinks
yeah why don't you just put it in the
ice bucket
it was a six-pack [ __ ] six-pack's not
gonna fit in there what am i a [ __ ]
jerk-off
yeah no come on reach my friend that's
the right phrase
nouveau riche is that new rich if i was
rich sure would be the right phrase
existing poor i don't know um
all right this is from uh there we got
two or three left here this is from
david uh david duda uh
let's see this back to the car what's
the
this is what's the uh how long is
acceptable to leave the price
sticker or the package detail in the
window of your new car
that day what the [ __ ] i know that
that day they didn't even put mine on
the comb i wasn't even on the car
i get rid of oh listen i don't save the
[ __ ] sneaker box
i don't save the [ __ ] phone box i
don't save
any of that [ __ ] i want to get out of it
rip it up
throw it away i don't want to i want to
move past the purchase
leave that thing in the window what the
[ __ ] is that what are you showing off
driving around with a number with a
slash through it
i don't know if i ever told you we went
to i'd keep those up the one
those numbers on the on the windshield
yeah like the so i don't know if i ever
thought he went to
my brother needed a car he was hemmed up
and he went
and we were like we were looking at like
old used cars for like super cheap or
whatever and like
they're like oh the budgets i don't know
[ __ ] 5000 something whatever it was
and he was in high school or college and
um we're there with my mom we're walking
around she goes oh this one's only
this one's under this one's only one
thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars this one's only one thousand
nine hundred nine nine dollars this
one's only two thousand dollars it was
the year
i was like yeah that's a [ __ ] she's
sitting there looking like a 2000 lexus
being like oh it's 19 you know
it's only two thousand bucks i'm like
don't you think it is it's weird all
these cars are [ __ ]
all within three dollars of each other
you're ditzy bro
that's pretty funny yeah um all right
and this is the last one this is a
visual that we'll have i'll have to send
t-bone the uh
the thing for um it says if you've ever
had these at your house you are
garbage see but i don't have to say that
let me see but for the listener it's
the the small corona salt and pepper
shakers
dirt ball city you stole that from a
[ __ ] taco joint yeah that's a
trap that is a tough [ __ ] look man
that's
trash that's one if you if i go over the
house you know that's never
clean either no there was always a
couple pieces of pepper or something
yeah yeah yeah you ever go to a place
where they put a little rice in with the
salt
is that classy or trashy it's uh
it preserves it longer and doesn't
there's like the natural oils in the
whatever they
let it called that don't let it clump up
big brain on a horse boy
goods mold man
yeah that's it baby let's wrap it up
dang
we love you do us a favor once you come
out and see us do a little [ __ ] ayg
live little stand-up comedy
april 20th at raleigh good night in
raleigh
north carolina and then the next night
we're going to be cruising down the
nashville
tennessee hashville tennis key that's
right over there at zany's and doing the
show
again come out and see us uh sign up for
[ __ ] patreon get yourself some cards
uh we love you and we'll see you next
week peace